10 دول انضمت لافتتاح فعاليه موسم رياض
الاكبر في بوليفارد ورد التي جمعت مختلف
المدن والعواصم الاسيويه والغربيه وحتى
العربيه العربيه رصدت بعضا من الدول
وتجولت العواصم المختلفه في اول يوم
لافتتاح بوليفارد
من اقصى الشرق الى اقصى الغرب سافر زوار
موسم الرياض لعشر دول وابحر في تفاصيلها
التي خطفت انفاسهم بتصاميم الخارجيه
وازيائهم لافته وذلك مع افتتاح ضمن
فعاليات الموسم الرياض
الصين استقبل الضيوفها عبر الوان الجدران
الحمر وتصميم المباني المعروفه بالاسقف
المتدرجه التي تناديهم بصمت وفخامه
تعبير حقيقي عن الاصاله والطعام يبدو شهيا
وبنتي حصلت على حلوى على شكل ديك او باندا
كانت مسليه حقا واستمتعنا هناك كثيرا
مثل هذه الامور في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه المدينه الرياض عشت هنا لمده 20
عاما قبل ان انتقل الى امريكا ولم اتوقع
ابدا ان هذه هي الرياضه الجديده
اغرقت الزوار بالحب والسعاده في قواربها
المصممه على شكل سياراته واخذتهم في جوله
بحريه داخل بوليفارد
بدوق البيتزا اذا كانت على نفس التوقعات
او على نفس ما يصفون انا ما قد رحت
ايطاليا بس بندوقه هنا نشوف اذا كان
الموضوع يستاهل من المسافر راح نسافر ان
شاء الله تصدق شيء فوق الخير يعني صليت
المغرب انا واخوي في المغرب
وتقهوينا في ايطاليا والحين ان شاء الله
مقابلين الشباب في اليمن كلها خلال ساعه
يعني ممكن اخر الليل نمر على فرنسا واحنا
طالعين التراث العربي
في المملكه المغربيه في القفطان المغربي
بالوانه الزاهيه كان لافته للزوار وفرصه
للتصوير وحتى البلغه تسمم بيد المغربيه
الاصليه مباشره وعلى طلب الجمهور من
الرياض شهد المتروك بالعربيه